is one of my least favorite food what i  hate anything on a plane i've i've hate  i hate a biscoff cookie i hate a pretzel  i hate nuts i could eat a peanut but  those are gone you hate the biscoff  coffee i hate it the biscoff cookie is  is a delight ah it's so hard you take  one bite you're you dip it in your  coffee  wow you get the airplane coffee oh i do  that's bad that's bad coffee with that  shitty cream or two nothing depresses me  more than a hotel creamer the powder no  well that's that's that's bottom of the  barrel it's like sars it's oh it's  anther actually yeah  but the little they're like for some  reason you don't need to refrigerate it  yes the coffee mate the little cup  pulled a little labia off of that thing  it's so great and it bubbles up it's  it's it's chemicals like the labia i dig  my tongue in just so it doesn't overflow  yeah  uh i love that by the way when you get  the tongue in the hole